me
c ん
はじめまして
今日は皆さんにゼンダーについてお話をします
gender 聞き慣れない言葉かもしれませんが一言で言えば男女の性による差別
あるいはそれに関連した話題とでも言うべきでしょうか
この世の中にはホモセクシャルの方もいらっしゃるし
トランスジェンダーの方もいらっしゃるということを十分に理解した上で
例えば社会に50%の男性
50%の女性がいてその割合が私たちが住んでいるこの環境に適切に反映されているの
かなとそういった問題点
です
私は極めて保守的な家庭で育ちました
私の母は方は鹿児島出身で7人兄弟ですからお盆になると総勢30名の家族が実家に
集まりましたよりないと宴会が始まるんですねそうすると私のおじいちゃんが
上座に座って長男次男三男
そして長女の婿次女の向こう3所の向こう
女子供はキッチンで食事を取ります
まあ女性の立場がよくお分かりになると思います
これは
私の学生時代の写真です現在九州大学にありましたが九州芸術工科大学環境設計学科の
時の写真です
よくご覧ください
31名のクラスメイトの中で女性はわずか1人です
40年前建築や都市計画あるいは
度国を学ぶ学生はほとんどが男子学生でした
大学を卒業して
東京の工業デザインの事務所に勤めることができました
そして会があって20代の後半にアメリカのロサンゼルスで仕事をする機会を得ました
そしてせっかくアメリカに行ったんだからと思うそういうことでもう一度
建築を勉強したいと思いまして uca 例の建築と都市へ都市計画の大学院に入り
ました
結婚して子供もいて大変経済的には厳しかったんですけれども非常に刺激的な授業を
受け
そして特に印象深かったのが女子学生です
スクエニ座って足を投げ出しそして下手くそなデザインでも真ん中に堂々と張って先生
たちの講評を受ける
そして何事にもつか買ってひと言で言うと生意気だったんです
私はそんな学生見たことがなかったんですね
で私自身
社会人の大学院生でしたから実写化で働いているアメリカ人の女性建築家インテリア
デザイナーグラフィックデザイナー
そういう方々とお友達になる機会がありました
当時日本はバブル経済の絶頂でマンション販売などで女性の感性を活かしたインテリア
デザインといった感じでキャメて競争的に女性を付加価値として売り出すそんな時代
でした
私はどうも違うなと思っていました
そこでこういう活躍するアメリカの女性たちをどこか日本に何らかの方法で紹介したい
思って取材して編集して sd
スペースデザインという雑誌を発行しました
これがその雑誌です
この中では例えば1984年のロサンゼルスオリンピックのグラフィックを手がけたで
頃サスマンや
ほとんど全員が女性で構成されているランドスケープの紛失
burton 元のスピッツあるいはだんなさんと一緒に都市計画や大きな
ショッピングセンターを手掛ける
ジェントンプソンなど26人の女性建築家デザイナーを紹介しました
その中に私がな学んだ ucla でのドローレス拝殿教授もいます
私の人生に非常に大きな影響を与えた人です彼女はハーバード大学を卒業して
ジェンダーの視点からアメリカの都市計画の様々な問題に取り組んでいます
そして現在エール大学で今日
麺をとっている方です
例えば彼女が書いた本の中でだグランドメスティック revolution
日本語の翻訳で火事大革命というのがあります
その中で彼女はこう通ってます
なぜ女性は家事をするようになったのか
その家事は正当な評価を受けているのか
そしてその経済価値はわれわれの大きな経済のシステムの中でちゃんと位置づけられて
いるのか
あるいは wii デザイニングでアメリカンドリー人
翻訳はアメリカンドリームの再構築これは
前の太平洋戦争の時に戦時中アメリカ女性たちは国内で軍艦や飛行機をつくっていまし
たてに技術を持ちながら子どもたちを育ててそして
戦場の男たちを支えていたんです戦争が終わって男どもが戦場から帰ってきました
そうすると手に職を持った女性たちは職場を男どもに分け私
そして女性たちに与えられたのが郊外の住宅ですか前に囲まれてそして女性は家事をし
なさい
子育てをしなさいそういうステレオタイプが女性に押し付けられたのです
そして現在お父さんとお母さんがいた子どもがいでー
そういう典型的な家族がなくな技巧外の住宅地は大きな問題を抱えることになっている
んです
もう一つ
大パワーをペース場所の力というのがあります
これはジェンダーから問題を展開してアメリカの歴史を支えてきたのは名もない
アメリカ人
例えばヒスパニックのアメリカ人あるいは日系中国系の
そういったアメリカ人その人たちが日々重ねてきた
活動があたかも地層のようにアメリカの都市の中に記憶のように保存されているその
ことの重要性を訴えたのがドレス入るんです
私は非常に印象深く今までハードを中心として建築教育を受けた私のってとっては本当
に目からウロコの大きな刺激でした
失礼
これが翻訳です
そして
私は皆さんに
こう問いかけたいんです
これなじみの写真ですがいったいこの街は誰が作ってきたのでしょうか
もちろん検察会社それも正しい
でも私が頭痛いのはこの街は誰がビジョンを描いて構想して設計して作ってきたかと
いうことです
アメリカでおいてはアメリカの専門家集団
圏地下教会 aia というのができたのが
1857年日本では江戸時代末期です
それから30年経った1888年に初めての女性建築家が aia に登録されました
それから70年 aia という組織ができて100年経った1958年に至っても
女性の建築家
わずか1%です
日本においては明治時代
イギリス人の建築家ジョサイアコンドルという人が
お雇い外国人として東京校風で後部学校
現在の東京大学で建築を教えていましたその教え子の一人が東京駅を設計した辰野金吾
です
それいない
有名大学を中心として男たちによる建築家の王道が出来上がったんです
そして戦後その王道の中心にいたのが皆さんご存知の有名な建築家丹下健三です
彼らは1964年の東京オリンピックの時に吊り構造の代々木の体育館を設計し
1970年大阪万博の時の開場を設計しそして超高層の東京都庁を設計しています
彼の建築は年を構成する1つの要素ではありますがその中で暮らす人々の営みや生活に
ついて
思慮深いものではありませんでした
丹下健三はこう言っています
インテリアははしたなく女々しく
女子供がやる領域だ
そして現在に至るまで
断裁建築家はこのような立派な建築を作り続けています
2001年
ニューヨークへ行
大事件が起こりました
ワールトレイセンターの爆破事件ですこれはテロ辞典として有名ですが
県歯科の分野でも大きな衝撃を与えました設計したのは日経雨次回アメリカ人実山崎
です
兼題合理主義の下で当時の建築技術の粋を集めて作った建物そして
等3等権力の集中したニューヨーク
そこでこの爆破事件が起こったんです
あえて誤解を避けずに恐れずに言えばテロリストは実に的確な目標を選択したんです
あたかも sf 映画のようにこの車
建物が爆破されて崩壊する様はまさに建築家に無力感を与えたんです
私はジェンダーの話から始めました
今女性の方々が例えば子育ての問題や男女共同参画
職場における男女平等の
様々な活動をされていますそれは素晴らしいことなんです
ところが私が頭痛いのはじゃあそのような活動が一体何を前提として行っている活動
なるか
つまりこれまで面々として作られた男が作った空間あるいは政治経済のシステムの中に
組み込まれる形であらゆる分台を50あらゆる分野の50%を目指すそれが果たして
正しいことなんだろうかというふうにも思います
ギリシャのアクロポリスの時代から男の両駅公共空間と女性脳両駅して起伏空間は明確
に分かれていましたそれは空間だけの問題ではなくて
まさに政治空間の分別でもあったわけです
1900年の初め頃アメリカでは女性建築家
女性活動家の手によって家事つまり例えば洗濯やキッチンや子育てを社会化しようと
いう動きがありましたみんなで共同でそういう家事をやろうという動きです
400以上の実験的な住居が造られましたが残念ながら1931年アメリカ政府の
フーバー委員会によって子育て
郊外型住宅そして中着所有という方針が打ち出されてそれが終わりを迎えたのです
最後になりますが
私は地下将来もう一度女性と環境について
雑誌か本を出してみたいと思います
その時例えば100人の建築家を選んだときその中には当然私の娘も含まれるかもしれ
ません
その時に半分が女性建築家であってほしいと望んでいます
たぶん彼女によって作られる建築はあるいは環境は自然と調和しそしてあえて
ジェンダーを問わずても私たちが今までに見たことがないような環境を作ってくれるの
ではないでしょうか
がんばれ女性たち
ありがとうございました